[Musique]
qui parmi vous est pleinement conscient
de son potentiel
je viens de terminer mon cm2 et je
revois encore ma mère qui me dit en
regardant mon bulletin de notes philbert
ça va pas ah bon pourquoi tu es notre
centre bonne il faut que tu restes à ta
place tu seras maçon comme ton père à 10
ans quand vous recevez sens c'est à vous
refroidit moi je suis resté en
hibernation pendant huit ans jusqu'à la
fin de ma scolarité et pourtant je
rêvais d'être un record
il faut savoir que
mon neil hannon moutier mon père m'a
enseigné des valeurs très fortes
courage et travail mais le travail
laborieux pas le travail intellectuel
ça c'est pour les feignants en tout cas
c'est ce qui m'a pris
mon père lui malheureusement est décédé
à 83 ans sans savoir lire et écrire ceci
explique peut-être cela
après huit années de scolarité en
alternance avec la pêche à la palourde
je suis rentré directement dans la vie
active comme ouvriers à la chaîne dans
une usine de renault
toujours les mêmes gestes sur les mêmes
machines
dans le même ordre et là je me suis juré
sortir ce carcan social où mes parents
m'avaient entraîner malgré moi
mais comment par le seul moyen à
l'époque à ma disposition
la formation continue
et oui la formation continue mais aussi
les valeurs que mes parents m'ont
enseigné courage et travail
j'étais ouvrier à la chaîne mon chef
d'equipe vient me voir et me dit c'est
bien philbert vous êtes courageux et
travailleur mais ce n'est pas votre bac
alors tout naturellement cette époque
j'ai des idées prend des cours du soir
chaque époque là en prendre pour 20 ans
et une fois que j'ai purgé ma peine
j'ai obtenu un diplôme d'ingénieur en
organisation
incroyable c'est qu'après 20 ans de
formation continue
repetita c'est l'attitude d'un drh d'une
grande entreprise qui me dit d'un ton
paternaliste et condescendant monsieur
corps brochot c'est très bien vous êtes
courageux et travailleur mais oui chez
nous un arabité directeur production
un ingénieur des mines directeur usine
après technicien directeur département
c'est dommage vous n'êtes pas dans la
nomenclature
alors je me suis dit là il ya un bug
d'un système managérial
j'en ai fait mon métier non un combat
j'en ai fait un combat pourquoi parce
qu'en 20 ans d'évolution d'ouvriers à
directeur en passant par technicien
responsable ingénieur j'ai pris
conscience qu'ils avaient des talents
cachés à tous les niveaux hiérarchiques
et qui méritait d'être révélée
et j'en ai
des personnes
prétendre que moi et qui n'ont pas pu
évoluer
pourquoi
selon une légende indienne un jour un
fermier trouve à 9 daigle il ramassa il
déposa dans son poulailler en espérant
qu'une poule v1 couver et ce fut le
corps via un être un aiglon qui s'est
mis à vivre avec une portée poussins et
à grandir avec les poules à caqueter
comme une poule à picorer comme une
poule à s'envoler sur quelques mètres en
perdant quelques plumes comme une poule
ils supporter même les moeurs du coq et
le soir ils avaient peur du renard qui
rôdent va bref il vivait comme une boule
coin un jour qui piquent aurait avec sa
compère la poule
il vit passer au dessus lui une ombre la
regardant un peu effrayé il vit un
oiseau magnifique majestueux et regarde
ça qu'on perd à l'effet ne rêve pas
c'est un aigle tu seras jamais comme lui
et lui il en rêvait lui d'être un aigle
et puis les années passèrent il devint
vieux très vieux et finit par mourir
sans savoir qu'il était le roi des
oiseaux
puissant fort rapide et avec une vue
perçante alors arrêtez de
comme des poules mouillées ne sait ne
considérait pas que vous êtes incapable
d'évolution ici on essayer de dénicher
l'aigle qui est en vous oui mais comment
il ya 30 ans quand j'ai pris des cours
du soir pour passer mon bac
électrotechnique il y avait une matière
qui me passionnait c'était
l'électrotechnique la productique pardon
alors j'ai décidé d'approfondir le sujet
avec un bac +2 en productique et là il y
avait une matière qui me passionnait la
gestion de production alors j'ai décidé
d'approfondir sujet avec un bac +4 en
section production et là encore il y
avait une matière qui me passionnait
l'organisation et j'ai passé un diplôme
d'ingénieur en organisation et ainsi de
suite avec le management le coaching et
les talents si bien je suis devenu un
expert comme le dit si bien
george bernard shaw 1 espère est
quelqu'un qui sait de plus en plus de
choses dans un domaine de plus en plus
restreint si bien qu'à la fin et c'est
tout ce rien plus sérieusement là encore
j'en ai croisé des personnes bien plus
intelligente que moi et qui n'ont pas
leur diplôme d'ingénieur
vous faire délier bâton
ap quand même je vous donnais je vous
parlais de l'outil qui m'a permis de me
révéler le bilan de potentiel
j'ai bien dit plus important de le bihan
potentiel j'ai pas dis bilan de
compétences
le bilan potentiel s'appuie sur quatre
domaines
l'intellectuel le relationnel
l'émotionnel et l'opérationnel on peut
dire que l'opérationnel correspond au
bilan de compétences
mais qui comptent que pour un quart du
bilan de potentiel
si je prends mon cas mon bilan de
potentiel révèle des capacités
d'analystes de 1 sur 10 et d'innovateurs
de 10 sur 10 et j'ai fait toute ma
carrière en tant qu'analyste mais il
n'ya pas que le potentiel
il ya aussi la passion la passion se
sont toutes les activités qui vous
animent au quotidien
professionnel loisirs
ce sont des activités que l'on fait avec
plaisir facilité sans voir le temps
passer
ce qui est intéressant c'est que quand
on
ces deux activités ces deux le bilan
potentiel et la passion on voit des
points communs et là vous avez les
bausch de votre métier idéal mais la
passion ça va aussi vous permettre de
maintenir la motivation et la
détermination pour aller jusqu'au bout
de chemin
ces moteurs
mais pour pas s'écarter du chemin il
faut visualiser son étoile comme les
rois mages oui comme héros nages
malheureusement à l'école on nous
enseigne à poursuivre un chemin selon
une pancarte unique capacités
intellectuelles en ignorant d'autres
pancartes capacités relationnelles
relationnel relationnel émotionnel et
opérationnel
et on poursuit son chemin en respectant
une carte préprogrammés bac bac + 2 3 4
et lorsqu'on relève la tête
trop souvent on s'aperçoit qu'on s'est
éloignée de son étoile
par méconnaissance de celle ci
d'ailleurs
d'où la nécessité de bien connaître son
potentiel et d'ajuster la formation
avant pendant et après
moi j'ai eu à le faire ça
s'y adapter ma
a sion
au départ son étoile on la voit pas très
bien on la voit même en distingue à
peine cependant quand on connaît bien
son potentiel et sa passion on arrive à
des pages et son projet professionnel
c'est-à-dire son étoile
et progressivement c'était tout abri rat
comme ce fut le cas pour moi et brillera
pour vous également
jouer et à l'heure quand j'étais jeune
je rêvais d'être avocat
malheureusement la cabane est tombée ce
chien à cause d'un carcan familial
pour autant mon rêve s'est transformé en
étoile à partir du moment où que que ma
passion s'est aligné avec l'étoile
je sais pas
d'aliments désastre mais pas loin pour
preuve quand j'étais directeur
j'adorais jouer le rôle de tuteur
et là je
que je préférais tuteur que directeur
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai fait
et médiers formateur animateur coach
conférencier et maintenant avocat des
talents cachés et je peux dire que je
vis ma vie d'aig avec beaucoup de
plaisir
il faut aller jusqu'au bout du chemin et
pour pas calais
le moteur cale il faut lui mettre du
carburant et le carburant c'est l'auto
apprentissage j'ai j'ai inventé ma
propre méthode propre méthode d'auto
apprentissage est ce que j'ai appelé
d'ailleurs la spirale de révélations et
cette spirale
ces deux méthodes et je veux dire elle a
obtenu le trophée de la formation
continue décerné par le ministre et les
échos ça vous intéresse de la connaître
attention assist anti fikin vous êtes
des ingénieurs un lecture
expérimentation déploiement
lecture
vous êtes déçu non c'est une démarche
pragmatique pragmatique
en fait les cours ne représentait pour
moi que 20 % de mon apprentissage
les 80 % sont couverts par des lectures
sur des matières qui me passionnait
et après évidemment une fois que j'avais
bien emmagasiné cette lecture
chapero fournissait le sujet en
expérimentant sur des cobayes mes
collègues mes collaborateurs voir mes
clients au départ j'ai eu des doutes
quand même j'ai dit oui mais la
connaissance c'est quand même pas la
compétence
puis je me suis très vite rendu compte
qu'il n'y a aucune incidence
c'est pourquoi au royaume des aveugles
les borgnes sont rois
oui ils connaissaient pas la matière
donc je pouvais y aller j'espère y
monter et comme le disait si bien
nelson mandela je ne perds jamais
soit je gagne je sois j'apprends et
quand je gagnais
et beige jeu déployé sa auprès de mon
équipe
mais pour le déployer il faut le
maîtriser donc j'approfondis sait
mais contrairement
terre au capital et à l'immobilier les
connaissances la croix quand on les
partage et le partage et que mes équipes
eux-mêmes me renvoyer de la matière qui
rentrait dans ma spirale de baisse de
révélations et ainsi de suite c'est le
cercle vertueux
or les talents l'attend je suis venu
plaider une noble cause
la défense des talents cachés voir
gâcher
en résumé
je vous ai dit pour vous épanouir
d'abord il faut connaître son potentiel
et puis il faut visualiser son étoile
puis le chemin eh bien il ya un moteur
pour aller jusqu'au bout du chemin
c'est sa passion
mais sa passion faut pas kaka long cours
de route est alimenté par un carburant
qui est l'auto apprentissage
pour finir je voudrais parts
j'ai une conviction c'est votre
revo talent
c'est votre heure
chefs professionnels
est ce que vous avez envie de confier
votre richesse personnelle
quelqu'un d'autre
l'éducation de vos enfants
la gestion de votre maison
question des économies nouveau économie
alors pourquoi confier alors pourquoi
vous confiez votre richesse
professionnelle qui sont vos talents à
votre employeur à votre drh et à votre
responsable hiérarchique
pourquoi
vos talents l'attend
thil en friche
vous ne les cultiver pas ils laisseront
la place aux mauvaises herbes
en tout
r j'espère que j'ai réussi à réveiller
l'aigle qui est en vous aujourd'hui
oui oui je vois déjà
des yeux qui brillent persans dans la
salle merci
[Musique]